as many as 100 people may be dead after
one of the most devastating storms in
years struck the united states the state
of kentucky is hardest hit dozens there
are feared to have been killed in a
single factory many more were trapped in
an amazon site in illinois as twisters
ripped across state lines
the governor of kentucky has declared a
state of emergency
we are nearing the end of the most
severe tornado event in kentucky's
history
multiple tornadoes have touched down
and we have
damage and i believe over a dozen
kentucky counties this has been one of
the toughest nights in kentucky history
and some areas have been
hit in ways that are hard to to put into
words we're going to bring in u.s based
journalist and meteorologist matthew
cappucci matthew possibly up to a
hundred people are dead are you
surprised by the scale of this disaster
you know to be honest i didn't think
that in today's day and age with the
warning systems we have we'd still be
seeing tornadoes with a hundred percent
death toll the last time this curve was
back in 2011 with the joplin missouri
tornado which killed 161 people and
before that you had to go back to june
9th 1953 to have a tornado in the united
states with roughly that many people
perishing so this is kind of as bad of
an event as you can possibly have with
the tornado that will likely span at
least four states was on the ground for
more than 300 kilometers this simply
doesn't really happen this is what's in
a 40 50 plus year event and the most
amazing part i think was the fact that
for a high antonio we're talking ef4 ef5
tornado we see debris lifted to about
eight nine thousand meters this time
around close to fifteen to sixteen
thousand meters so this event in all
respects was off the charts so given
that this was a once in a generation
event as you say could the extent of the
damage from this tornado been better
predicted and allowed people perhaps to
be better prepared for what was coming
so the unfortunate thing is that you
have two different sides of the coin you
have to look at scientific and really an
ingenuity in the way that we structure
our warnings and how we communicate them
now the warnings in all respects were
phenomenal more than two days out we
sounded the alarm for a high and severe
weather potential with a level four out
of five moderate risk of severe weather
issued by the storm prediction center so
we knew this was coming the warnings
blanketed the entire duration of where
that tornado actually went they were
there well in advance in some cases up
to 30 minutes in advance and even suited
up tornado warnings called tornado
emergencies communicating an immediate
imminent life-threatening situation so
the warnings were there the question did
people take them seriously or did they
fall on deaf ears
so the midwest
midwestern united states rather isn't a
stranger to extreme weather we see
extreme weather events there all the
time i mean did other things have to
fail to see this level of destruction
taking place in these states
i think one of the issues is definitely
public perception and that these folks
are kind of used to tornado warnings
that may cause some desensitization you
think about the fact that only one out
of every five tornado warnings actually
verifies with the tornado on the ground
so there's that there's about this
happened at night it's not traditional
severe weather season you do get a
second season in november december but
really folks associated with the biggest
severe weather potential as being in the
spring march april may when you have
more of that warm humid air a lot of
folks may have gone outside for
environmental cues waiting for damaging
wind or hail and that didn't really
occur with this setup because there
wasn't a lot of juice but there was so
much speed in the atmosphere so this
wasn't your traditional typical tornado
event i think one of the things that
occurred this time around the supercell
the rotating thunderstorm that produced
this tornado was located near a lobe of
low pressure kind of near what we call a
helped add mesology and really cause
this high end off the charts events
matthew capucci journalist and
meteorologist thanks so much for that
update
thank you
you